- We now have more founding
era documents from 1770,
about 1770 to 1830 than anybody
but the Library of Congress
and The National Archives.
We just bought a
massive collection,
the Smithsonian
was in the running.
I mean, it's massive.
That is all of the
Pilgrim history
and all of the history of
Jamestown and everything.
So we have the
largest collection
and we intend on putting 1619
in its place because
that is an absolute lie.
And there's something to say,
when you go, that's not true.
Oh, well, who are you?
Just the one that has
all of the documents
in their own handwriting
to say what happened.
(upbeat music)
- All right, guys.
I'm Dave Rubin and this
is "The Rubin Report."
We are live on location today.
Well, live to tape on
location today in Dallas
from The Blaze Studios,
with a guy who knows
a little something about The
Blaze Studios, Glenn Beck.
- How are you?
- Welcome to your studio.
- Thank you, thank you.
It's great to have you here.
- Well, thank you
for letting me play around
in your studio today,
I'm just bouncing around between
a hundred different shows
and talking to people and
seeing what's going on.
- It's kind of like our
little chocolate factory,
Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory.
- You sort of, at some level
I call Michael Malice, the
Willy Wonka of politics
but you might be the original
Willy Wonka of politics.
And you've got a big Willy
Wonka poster out there.
- Yeah we have a lot of,
I have the golden
ticket from Willy Wonka.
We have lots of costumes
from Willy Wonka.
I'm a collector of
almost everything.
- You're a true collector
and you've got stuff.
I didn't even tell you what
I wanted to talk about today.
And so as we're
taping this right now
it's Friday afternoon.
And supposedly Trump's
about to give a big speech.
So let's not even dive
into the day-to-day stuff.
I think people sorta know
what we think about
some of these things,
I was on your radio
show this morning.
We'll keep picking it up over
the next couple of weeks.
Obviously-
- I did talk to somebody
who is a big techie.
And he was like these
voting machines.
I talked to him since we talked.
He said these voting machines,
he said at 100% he believes
there is real foul goings on
with the voting machines.
- Well, I suppose we shall see.
And by the time
we finish in here,
Trump either could have
dropped the bomb or well,
it depends what the
bomb is, I suppose.
- ut with him it
might actually be.
- And by the way, today
is Friday the 13th.
So, you know the whole world
has led us to this moment.
But because you're a collector,
you have tons of stuff.
I mean, you've got
Darth Vader's helmet,
you've got Dorothy's
Ruby Red Slippers
you got the golden ticket,
Willy Wonka's golden ticket,
but you also have
some incredible stuff.
And you're building
a museum right now
dedicated to really
the history of America
and the stuff that you
talk about all the time.
- It's both the
good and the bad.
My partner in this
project is David Barton.
And he's been collecting all
the good things about America.
And my daughter, she
wanted to go to school
and they both hated history,
but they would come
home and I'd say,
what are you learning
about history?
And then I would
tell them the story.
And both of my older
daughters majored in history
and ended up loving it.
But my daughter came
to home and she said,
dad, I'm gonna major in history.
And I said, great.
And I said, we need great
American historians.
And she said ah, you know, dad,
your view of America
is just so utopian.
And you know, it's red,
white, and blue and apple pie
which wasn't exactly
true, but kind of,
and she said, it's
just too ugly.
It's really an ugly history.
And I'm thinking if my child
is saying that in my home,
what kind of nonsense
has been filled in?
And I said, I tell you
what, well, first of all,
what are you taking?
She said Greek
and Roman history.
And I said, oh, well,
that's completely bloodless.
- [Dave] Yeah,
you're good to go.
- There are no problems there.
And I said, here's the deal.
That's cool,
but I will read all the
dark things about history.
You have to read and research
some of the good things
because it's like
Winston Churchill.
You read about him in Europe.
He's a great guy.
You read about him from
the Indian perspective,
he's a fricking nightmare.
And it really bothered me
when I looked at both sides
because I'm a huge fan
of Winston Churchill.
Who's that guy?
The answer is he's both of
them, he's both of them.
History is about a trajectory.
Are you getting better
or are you getting worse?
Like our constitution says,
a more perfect nation,
not a perfect nation.
We should be striving to
be more perfect every day.
So, I started collecting all
of the really dark things.
We now have guillotines from
the French Revolution we have-
- That was an odd way for
me to show up in Texas.
You bring me immediately
into the room
and here's the guillotine-
- And the electric chair.
- The electric chair, yeah.
- We have the first or second
electric chair ever made.
It was used in the
New York Penitentiary.
And I have that because I
hate Edison, I hate him.
He was a bad dude
and the electric chair was
all about just getting people
to get away from Tesla's
DC power or AC power.
- So when you say
he was a bad dude,
you're talking about
what he did to Tesla
and just the business
type things that he did
and the way he controlled
everybody and all that?
- Our history is not told right.
So I started collecting
these things.
We now have more
founding era documents
from 1770, about 1770
to 1830 than anybody
but the Library Of Congress
and The National Archives.
We just bought a
massive collection that
I mean, the Smithsonian
was in the running.
I mean, it's massive.
That is all of the
Pilgrim history
and all of the history of
Jamestown and everything.
So we have the
largest collection
and we intend on putting 1619
in its place because
that is an absolute lie.
And there's something to say,
when you go, that's not true.
Oh, well, who are you?
Just the one that has
all of the documents
in their own handwriting
to say what happened.
- Yeah, well, you've
been ahead of the curve
on a couple of things
over the years.
And I suspect that
this is going to be
another one of those times
because people are ready.
People, you know, there was
the pushback against 1619.
It took a while, but
there was a push back.
And then they started
slowly retracting some of it
and deleting tweets
and things like that.
But the next piece is actually
giving the counter narrative
and having the real
breadth of work behind it.
- Right, it doesn't matter.
Don't take it from me, look
at the original documents.
We're going to start a
class online, it'll be free.
And you can either
do it in person here,
or you can take it online.
And it is the truth about
our founders and our nation.
Who are we?
Let me show you
- So you brought a
ton of stuff here.
I don't even know
what you have here.
We're we're doing
this on the fly.
Yeah.
- So this is something
nobody ever sees.
This is the engraving
of the first draft
of The Declaration
Of Independence
in Thomas Jefferson's
handwriting.
It's four pages, and here
are the other two pages.
- Unbelievable.
- All right, notice on the sides
you'll see on the margins,
if you've ever used
Microsoft Documents
and you've made a change,
it always puts off to the
side who made the change,
what the change was and date.
- Right here, oh my God.
- It is in their handwriting,
when they changed something,
they crossed it out and
then they put on the margin,
B. Franklin, J. Adams
and what they
changed on the day.
Is that not crazy?
- God, it's like, wait, so
I asked you this yesterday
but can you just explain
people how, first,
I think it's hard for
people to understand
that these things
still exist, right?
I think that's one thing,
but how do you possibly
attain these things?
Like how does this come to be?
- Some of these things
have been donated to us
for preservation
and because they don't
want them in public hands,
they don't want them
held by the government,
held in universities
because we want them to
always be on display,
always to be available online.
So you could go use it
as an original source.
We're currently taking
all the documents we have
and digitizing them.
So it's not just a
big book or, you know,
something online
that says what it is,
it shows you in their
own handwriting.
- You know, it's incredible
when you look at this
and you think about
all the bills that
are passed now,
when you see the, you
know the stacks of paper
that you know, nobody's
read and it's like-
- It's the most important
document in the world,
four pages, four pages.
Okay, so the
Declaration is first,
a dear John letter
the first part,
except it's dear George,
it's not us, it's you.
And it's because you
don't understand us,
this is who we are.
And then it goes into
the second section
which is the usurpation.
These are all the things
that you've done to us.
If you get to page three,
and this turns everything
around on its head,
and this is available, you
can find this document online.
People always say,
and I have too,
how did Thomas Jefferson say,
all men are created equal and
not know what he was saying?
Well, then I've
always had to go to,
well, it was a different time.
He did struggle.
He couldn't give his slaves
away cause he was in debt,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But that's not a good answer,
it's not a good answer.
This is, this in
his own handwriting.
Every usurpation from
page two to page four
is about one to two lines.
This usurpation goes from here.
That's a whole large-
- That's a good chunk-
- Paragraph, okay.
And if you look at it
his handwriting changes.
And he said that this
King has waged cruel war
against human nature itself,
violating its most sacred
right of life and liberty,
in the persons of
a distant people
who never offended him,
captivating them and
carrying them into slavery
in another hemisphere
to incur miserable death
in their transportation.
This warfare on humans,
the opprobrium of infidel
powers is the warfare.
And then it's capitalized,
Christian, and underlined,
the Christian King
of Great Britain
determined to keep an open
market where, capital letters,
the only thing capitalized
in this document
are the words United
States of America
at the very heading,
he capitalizes,
where he has on an open market,
men should be bought and sold.
He is saying the African
American is not a slave,
he's a man.
Now he goes on to say,
we've been fighting him,
he blocks us every turn.
We've tried to get rid of
this poison, but we can't.
He keeps blocking us, now
he's telling the slaves,
you can gain your
freedom if you kill us
and we're trying to free him.
So he's doubly
injuring these people.
It's an amazing paragraph.
So why isn't it in The
Declaration Of Independence?
Because John Hancock stood
up before they selected
even who would write
the declaration,
they stood up and said, okay,
we know if we aren't
all 100% in lock step,
the King is going
to say, Virginia.
you know what, you
don't agree with him
and he'll divide us,
we cannot be divided.
Who here says we
have to be unanimous?
Before this was written,
all States said unanimous.
That's why the
finished draft says
the unanimous declaration of the
United States of America,
Declaration Of Independence.
He brought this back.
Every word, every line
had to be voted on.
when they got to that,
out of the 13 colonies
two, two said, no, that
leaves 11 colonies,
and importantly, Virginia,
which is a Southern colony,
George Washington,
Thomas Jefferson,
all of the big names
are in Virginia.
They said yes to that paragraph,
only two colonies said no.
So help me out,
how are all of our
founders racist, dirt bags,
didn't know what slavery was?
They clearly did.
So a couple of other things
that I think change history,
you know what this is?
Have you ever seen this?
- I mean, it's gotta be,
well there's Japanese
markings under there, right?
So this is, oh God, well
that's not dropping.
No, it's certainly not
the dropping of the nukes.
- Okay, but that's
what this is about.
The back.
There were 70 million
of these dropped
by Allied Air Force,
the American Air force.
And it's gives the name
of 12 different cities.
It says we have a bomb
that has more powerful,
that is more powerful
than all of the weaponry
we have dropped in
Europe, in one bomb.
If you're in one
of these 12 cities,
Nagasaki and Hiroshima
were two of those cities,
please leave now.
If your emperor
will not surrender,
we will be left with no
choice, but it is so horrific,
please take food and
water and clothing
and leave these cities.
We're not targeting you.
Please leave,
those supplies will be in
very short supply afterwards.
You were shocked if
you picked one up,
what country tells their
people, we're coming,
we have this bomb, we're
going to drop it by this date
and it's going to happen
in one of these cities?
- Well, there's one
country that does it now,
but the left is not
thrilled with that country.
- One, how come we
don't know about that?
Every time we hear
about America is so bad,
they always bring
up the atomic bomb.
Well, can you throw this in?
- [Dave] This is incredible.
- Yeah, this is an original
letter to the Hitler Youth
from Neville Chamberlain.
This talks about
I welcome the intention of
the German Youth Movement
to devote a special issue of
the magazine to your ideals.
In it, he talks about
he's met with the Fuhrer,
he's a man of peace and-
- [Dave] All the hopes of
Germany are set upon you.
- The Hitler Youth,
Neville Chamberlain,
that one I got just because,
appeasement never, ever works.
- Listen to the last line.
I mean, I know you've read it,
but the admirable motto of
the year of understanding,
which you have chosen
for the year of 1938
shows the part that you
are playing in this work.
I mean talk about
appeasement and confusion.
- Yup, a couple of other
things, this is wonderful.
Read it.
- "I, Ronald Reagan
do solemnly swear
"that I will faithfully execute
"the Office Of The President
Of The United States
"and will to the best of my
ability preserve, protect,
"and defend the constitution
of the United States.
"So help me, God.
"Ronald Reagan,
January 20th, 1980."
And on the top to Nancy,
who brightens the,
is it the corner?
Who brightens-
- Who brightens every corner.
- Who brightens the
corner where we are.
- Yeah, so that's-
- That's the one.
- That's the one
that was held right
in front of him as he was
taking the oath of office.
And how many people,
how many people really
mean that, mean those words?
Have you ever heard
of Colonel Stone?
He was a guy, he was military,
actually the guy
who first protected,
kind of our first
secret service agent,
first protected Abraham Lincoln
when he was coming
in to Washington for
the very first time.
He's the guy who said,
we got to get you out
and we're going to have
you go into a theater.
We're going to have
you change clothes.
You're going to hunch over
like a little old lady.
And we're going to get you
out the back into a carriage.
And we're going to
get you on train,
take you to Pittsburgh,
because everybody's
going to think
that you're going to Washington.
We'll get you to Pittsburgh.
They will take another
train into Washington
and no one will know.
It saved his life,
saved his life.
He became a Colonel
in the Northern Army
in the fight, in The Civil War.
And he refused to
hate the other side.
He just thought they were wrong,
but he refused to hate them.
That caused a lot of problems
with a lot of politicians
because they were
whipping up the hate.
It's why Lincoln's
vice-president walked out
and was so upset.
It's why we have a picture of,
the only picture that
is of John Wilkes Booth
and Abraham Lincoln
in the same picture
and Booth is behind him.
And it's at the second
inaugural address
and he actually tried
to kill him there
because he was so enraged
that this guy would say,
let's come together,
let's heal these wounds.
He was enraged by that
and really wanted to kill
him with his own hands
and attempted to do it.
Well, this Colonel became
a Colonel in The Civil War.
He was blamed for something
that he never did.
It was a trumped up charge
'cause he became very
unpopular with Congress.
Congress tried him.
He wasn't allowed to
even put on a defense.
He wasn't allowed to speak
in front of Congress.
They never came to a verdict
because they know that he
would have been set free.
So he was held in prison.
He was held in prison, I
think for about six months,
Lincoln found out
about it and said,
what the hell are you doing?
Charge him, convict
him, or let him go.
And they didn't.
They waited another
six or eight months.
Lincoln found out about
it again and just said,
get him out, he was so upset.
He went over, he left
the United States
and he went over and he was
working for the French in Egypt,
years later, he comes back.
He's thinking, he's
hoping everybody
is going to forget
about those things
that they said about him.
He's at home, he gets
a knock on the door,
no one will hire him, they do
remember no one will hire him.
He opens up the door.
It's two representatives from
the United States government.
And they said, Colonel,
we understand you were
in Egypt and you were
working with the French.
And he said, yes.
And they said, so do you
speak and read French?
Yes.
Good, 'cause we just
got a big box of stuff
and we don't know how
to put it together.
It was the Statue Of Liberty.
- [Dave] Oh my God.
- This is his purchase
order for all of the stones
for the base of the
Statue Of Liberty.
He's the guy, the guy who
could be the worst on America,
that has every reason
to be pissed at America.
He builds the Statue Of Liberty.
- This is incredible.
"Colonel, please
inform us at what price
"you can furnish during
the summer of 1884,
"about 8,000 cubic
yards of stone.
"According to the sample
furnished to you just-"
- [Glenn] Isn't that nuts?
- Just incredible.
- So this is an example, this
is early American texting.
Do you know who do you know
who Matt Anthony Wayne is?
- I feel that I should.
- He's a general on the
American side in the Revolution,
he was great, but
he was an animal.
Okay, this is a picture
of him in the battle of,
I'm trying to remember
which battle, Stony Point.
So Stony Point, he's
shot in the head.
He's got a bullet, a big,
huge bullet in his head
and he keeps going
and they're like
general, general, general, and
he's like, come on, let's go.
And so they win and
they bring them in
and they're like we have to get
the bullet out of your head.
He's like fine, fine,
but I need a piece
of paper and pencil.
So this is his letter to
George Washington that says,
hey, we won, and it says-
- Because he's got
the bullet out.
- Before he's got the bullet,
he writes this letter and
it's from Stony Point,
16 July 2:00 AM,
"Dear General, the
Fort and the Garrison
"with Colonel
Johnstone are ours."
Listen to this line.
"Your officers and
men behaved like men
"who are determined to be free."
I read that line and I thought,
what does that even mean
to live your life
determined to be free?
Most Americans are not there.
So he writes it to
George Washington,
it's folded up.
George Washington then takes it
and he puts it in his letter.
This is a letter to
the governor who says,
hey, I want to tell
you about the war.
Here's the Colonel's message.
So he takes this message,
puts it in his letter.
That's his signature,
no, it's one of these.
I think this is the
Washington signature.
No, that's George
Washington signature there.
There he does it.
He puts that letter in here.
He sends it to the governor.
This is the governor's letter,
where he takes both
of these letters,
this is texting, this
is early American texts.
- God, that these things exist.
- Do you know who
Raoul Wallenberg is?
- He got Jews out of Russia.
It's like yeah.
- He was killed by the
Russians, he was in Budapest.
I got this for Christmas
one year from my wife
and she handed me a box
and she gave it to me
and then she took it
back and she said,
I can't give this to you.
And I said, why?
She said, I'll give
it to you tomorrow.
I said what?
She said, it's Christmas,
you will spend all day crying
if I give this to you.
And I'm like, I'm not gonna
cry, she said, promise?
'Cause I know you, you will.
And I said, I won't cry.
She gave it to me, I spent
all Christmas crying.
This is one of the most
powerful things I own.
This is a Schutz-Pass.
This is a letter of protection
signed by Raoul Wallenberg.
We asked him, okay, the
United States went to him.
He's like, I don't know
what you would compare,
the Nordstrom family.
The Wallenberg family was
like the Nordstrom family
on steroids.
And they were very
powerful, very influential,
blah, blah blah.
I think he was one
of the younger sons.
And the United States
went to him and said,
listen, we think the Germans
are killing the Jews.
We need somebody to
be our eyes and ears.
Would you go over
with your government
and work in your embassy
and tell us what's going on?
He said, reluctantly, yes,
he knew what was at stake.
He gets over there.
He sees what's going on,
he not only reports back.
He starts doing
this and his King,
in letter after
letter, says stop,
you know, we have
the Germans here.
What are you doing?
We are in trouble because you
are making all of these Jews,
citizens.
This was a pass that said they
don't have to wear the star.
This person now
belongs to Sweden.
He would take these
and he would print them
and sign them and
he'd go to the trains.
And he'd stuff them
in between the cracks
of the cattle cars, where
all the Jews were in.
He'd stuffed them in
and he'd stand on the
top of the last car.
And he'd say, stop the train,
you have the wrong people.
These people are my citizens.
And they would unload.
And everybody who
had one was free.
The problem is he didn't
know when to stop.
And, the Russians were
coming in and he said,
one of the people with the
Schutz-Pass said, Raoul,
you've got to come with us.
You've got to get out now.
And he said, no, the
Russians are right there.
They can't be as
bad as the Germans.
There's too many people
that we'll leave behind.
So he was last seen running
into the soldiers of Russia.
We don't know whatever
happened to him.
The United States of
America didn't even ask,
didn't even ask
until Gerald Ford,
there's a couple of
endings to the story.
One that he died in a work camp
in the late sixties,
early seventies,
others was that he was shot
on the ground in Budapest,
which we doubt because Stalin
wanted to interrogate
him himself, personally.
The most likely death
was that he was tortured
and treated horribly and
died before 1955, I think.
- I just wanna clarify
one thing though,
you said that they were
my citizens of Sweden,
but you meant Budapest, or am I-
- He was making the Jews in
Budapest citizens of Sweden.
So he was invoking the
protection of the King
of Sweden, which caused
Sweden all kinds of trouble.
- Okay, got it, got it,
I thought you were saying
that he was somehow being
able to do this in Germany
by saying that they
were citizens of-
- No, no, no, no,
they were in Budapest,
and they were being
claimed as Swedish citizens
so they could travel.
- I'm embarrassed that I
don't know more about this.
- This guy, most people
don't know who he is.
This is, I found this in auction
and this is so nothing
on its own about this,
it says, January, 2013, this
is a Russian cigarette case
that happened to be carried,
and it was all explained,
but no one tied it to this.
And when I saw it for sale,
I was like, oh my gosh,
this cigarette case was
carried by a man that was
in the brigade that
went into Budapest,
that he ran into.
This cigarette case, on it,
it says in Russian, let's
kill all the Jews and go home.
As he's saying, they
can't be as bad.
This is who he's running to.
One last piece that I brought.
- I saw this one right
when we sat down,
I said, who's is that?
You said, wait.
- John Huntsman,
John Huntsman Senior
was a dear friend of mine.
And he said, who
are your heroes?
And I told him a few people.
And he came to my
office a few weeks later
and he sat down, he looked
at my desk and he said,
I see the pictures
of your family.
Where are your heroes?
And I said, what do you mean?
He said, if you don't gaze
upon the faces of people
that you want to be like,
when you have a tough moment,
you have to look down and
see somebody who stood.
That's why I like Raoul
Wallenberg so much,
this amazing, amazing man.
This is a copy of "Mein
Kampf" all in lambskin,
given by Hitler himself.
And if you see the book plate.
- Franz Schenk Freiherr
Von Stauffenberg.
- You know who that is?
Von Stauffenberg,
General Von Stauffenberg
or what was he?
I think he was a general,
Von Stauffenberg, you
see the Tom cruise film?
That's Von Stauffenberg.
Von Stauffenberg fought against
the Nazis from the inside.
He's the guy who went and
planned, placed the bomb.
I actually don't have it here,
but I have the napkin
from that bombing
that was said to be the one
that Hitler had at that time.
It's bloodstained,
shrapnel holes through it.
This is his copy
of "Mein Kampf."
When he said I'm not a Nazi,
you know not only
because of what he did,
but the pages are perfect.
These books had
never been opened.
- God, it's eerie
just holding this.
- It is, isn't it?
And it's a weird thing
cause it's "Mein Kampf,"
but it's Von Stauffenberg's.
And don't judge people
by what they read
or what they have or
what they might have.
Don't judge people and he
and Dietrich Bonhoeffer,
Raoul Wallenberg.
These guys all acted
because nobody would act
when they could.
No one, the people,
I went to Auschwitz
and I brought my
kids, this is 2012,
and we were going to
Israel for vacation
and I was bringing
the whole family.
And I said, you can't go to
Israel for the first time
unless you pass through the
gates of Auschwitz first.
And my wife said, honey,
that doesn't make it
really a vacation.
And I said,
I want the kids to understand
why Israel is there.
And I want them to
make a choice now,
when they're young, who
are you going to be?
If the world goes
insane, who will you be?
And I engaged a
woman, she was oh,
in her eighties and so sweet.
She was one of the
Righteous Among The Nations,
which are the Christians
that saved Jews.
And we went through Auschwitz
and then we met with her.
And as we were leaving,
she told us this,
she sat down with a
family for like an hour.
It was just amazing.
And she told us how
at 16 years old,
she saw a Jew on the
street, just starving.
You could only feed a Jew,
I think 400 or 800
calories a day.
And just starving, and
it was a girl her age.
And she said, please,
do you have any food?
She said, I don't.
But if you come here tomorrow,
I'll bring you something.
So she came, she sat down at
the dinner table that night
with her mom and dad and
they were eating dinner.
And this a death
sentence, you feed a Jew,
you get the same thing
as a death sentence.
And she said, mama, dad, I
have to tell you something.
She said, I promised I would
bring some food tomorrow
to this Jewish girl
who was starving.
And she said, she remembers
the whole room, just stopping.
And her mom and dad
putting their spoon down
and looking at each other
and staring at each other,
not saying anything.
And then her mom got up,
she started pulling a big pot
out and put it on the stove.
And Paulina said, what
are you doing mom?
She said, well, if
she's coming for food,
she'll clearly have
hungry friends.
They saved about a hundred Jews.
So after I talked to her,
I said to her, Paulina,
what do you, how do I water
the seed of righteousness
in myself and in my family?
What do you do to
strengthen that?
That seed is there.
How do we make it into
a tree so we stand?
And she looked at me
and said something
that I thought was profound.
But up until recently, I
didn't truly understand.
And she said, you misunderstand,
the righteous didn't
suddenly become righteous.
They just refused
to go over the cliff
with the rest of humanity.
That's fantastic.
We don't have to do, you
don't ever have to get to
Von Stauffenberg,
all you have to do is
say, no that's crazy,
I know what I saw, that's
a car burning behind you,
that's Antifa, that's a riot,
that's looting, that's wrong.
- [Dave] Mostly peaceful.
- Yeah, it's not
mostly peaceful.
I'm sorry, you're going over
the cliff into insanity.
I'm standing where
I've always stood.
- You know, it's interesting,
I often think now,
now that I've been taking
some of these positions
that aren't thought
of as popular
or okayed by
mainstream or whatever,
that the only thing to
fear is fear itself.
And I've been thinking
about that a lot lately
that the more that I say,
the things that I
believe to be true,
that happened to be against
the mainstream things.
The more I get over that,
because if you can
get over the fear,
then if it's true
that we're on a list
and they're coming for
us, then we're on a list,
and by the way, pretty much
everyone's on the list.
And that's why there's
that famous thing.
You know, they came
for the Jews first.
It's like, we're all
part of this thing,
but it's a very strange time
that you can show me
some of these things,
founding documents
from the United States,
documents about saving
Jews during World War Two.
And it feels like something
that's kind of now.
- Only if people don't
find their courage.
I truly believe and this is
why I think you're so powerful,
courage is contagious, it
is, not everybody's a leader,
not everybody's willing
to step out into danger,
not everybody's willing to lose
all their friends
or to whatever,
but when they see
someone risk everything
and they see them on a list,
if you can get them early
enough, they'll step out.
But the longer you
wait, the worse it gets,
that's Bonhoeffer,
was a pacifist,
was involved in Von
Stauffenberg's coup, how?
He's a pacifist.
He said, there's nothing
else we can do at this point
because it's too late.
The people's hearts
had turned to stone
and you couldn't turn them.
We have to find a way to
make sure that our hearts
and the hearts of everybody
we know, stay soft,
and see people as
people, not enemies.
- You know, when I was
on tour with Jordan,
one of the things that
he would bring up often,
because he would talk about
the parallels to Nazism
to some of the authoritarian
movements of the day.
And he would say to
everyone in the crowd,
he'd say you know,
there's 3000 of you
sitting out here right now.
And I guarantee you that every
single one of you would think
that you wouldn't be a Nazi
if this was 1936 Germany.
And that proves probably
that you would be.
And I always thought that
that was pretty powerful.
We all think we would
do the unpopular thing.
do the risky thing.
We all judge everybody by
our standards of today.
- I'm not sure I'd
stand in the end.
I mean, a friend of
mine, Marcus Trell,
I said to him, how do you
stand torture and not break?
And he said, Glenn, everyone
breaks, everyone breaks.
He said, but the ones
who break the fastest
and the loudest are
the ones who will say,
I'll stand, oh, I'll stand,
because they haven't
thought about it.
It's why I wanted to bring
my kids to Auschwitz.
I need you to feel it.
So you can think about it
and really look at
this as a possibility.
And once you do that and you
realize by the grace of God
I'll stand, then you're ready.
But we have got to prepare
ourselves now to be ready
because if you're ready
now, the problems go away.
They think you're sheep.
I mean, I asked you on a
podcast with you the last time.
Where's the line?
What line do you have
as an individual that
you say I won't cross?
Well, I won't go there.
I mean, if I said to
you last summer, yeah,
they're going to tell us
that we can't have
Thanksgiving with our family,
that we have to wear
a mask all the time.
And the president is
going to make that mandate
and they're going to
shut down the economy.
You and I, and everybody else
would have said never, never.
- I would have said you know,
maybe they're right
about that bad guy.
- Right, you would've, you
would've, it's insane to think,
look where we are.
And now all of a
sudden that's normal.
It's the new normal.
- Yeah, they get you with
that phrase the new normal,
because there's an implicit,
oh, accept it, it
it's implicitly,
it's here, so you
better accept it.
- So the thing about war is
war is just about
changing leadership,
borders and financial systems.
That's what war is really about
for the people up at the top.
And it's usually so horrible
that a society even,
great ones never go back
to the way they were
because you're so
willing to accept peace.
I just want to go back to normal
that you never
reset back to normal
and you'll accept
almost anything.
Here we are.
Look at what we're willing
to accept at this point.
And I know I did when
they started talking
about the new normal
I was like, no, no, no, no, no,
I don't want a new normal,
I want normal, normal
- [Dave] Normal
will be just fine.
- How many people now would
just be happy if we just,
if we had, okay,
this is a new normal,
and they're gonna start you
know, letting things back up,
but it's never going
to get the way it was,
lots, lots would accept that.
- Is that why you care
so much about history
and these things,
because you feel like
it kind of grounds you
to do the current events
that you gotta do.
You gotta wake up every day.
You do how many hours a day
of talk, at least, at least?
- Five, give or take.
- That's a lot of airtime.
I know how much I talk and
it ain't five hours a day
but is that why you care
so much about history?
Because otherwise you're
just sort of spinning
in the morass of the day.
- I know clearly what
I'm fighting for,
I know clearly what
I'm fighting against
and my son was eight maybe.
And he started
taking Tae Kwon Do
and he had to go in
to get his first belt.
And I don't know why,
but he didn't expect
there to be a crowd there.
And when he was really
young crowds scared him
because of the stuff
that has happened to me,
that he witnessed as a little
kid, crowds scared him.
And he didn't want
to be around crowds
and he didn't want to
be noticed, you know?
And so we're going and
he's like, no, no, no,
there's a crowd,
no, there's a crowd.
And I'm like, Ray, it's
going to be fine, it's fine,
it's okay, just the parents.
They're just like us, we're
just watching your friends.
No, no, no, no, and
he really freaked out.
So I had to take him home
while his sister got her
belt and I'm driving home,
and I'm like, what
do I say to him?
And I, quite frankly,
it was a little pissed
but I didn't want
to be pissed at him,
'cause he wasn't, you know,
he wasn't misbehaving.
And we drove home and I
held his hand the whole time
but we didn't really talk.
'Cause I'm thinking
what do I say,
pulled into the house,
got into the house.
And I knew exactly
what I needed to do.
And I said come into
my library, come on,
sit down in the library.
And at that time, my whole walls
were covered with artifacts
and men determined to be
free and Raoul Wallenberg
and the picture of the
woman that he saved
and a picture of him, all
of the heroes, Rosa Parks,
everybody, Winston Churchill.
And we sat there on the couch.
I said, just want you
to look at the walls.
And he did.
And I said, why do you
think I have them up here?
And he said because
they're all heroes
and they weren't afraid,
and they do the thing.
And I said, no,
because I know each
and every one of them
was terrified of doing what
they knew they had to do.
They were terrified,
but they did it.
That's the lesson of history.
They're just like you,
Abraham Lincoln was
not a big, tall statue.
He knew he was going to die.
He knew it, he did it
anyway, he didn't want to,
nobody wants to.
Do you think Gandhi?
Well Gandhi may have, because
he was doing the hunger strike
but that was against his own
people, his own followers,
he was like you want to
be full of anger and rage,
I'm not with you.
And until my followers
stop acting that way
I'll starve myself to death.
I mean, these
people were amazing,
but all of them had
a change of heart
and didn't want to do it.
Bonhoeffer, he was here in
America, he escaped Germany.
And he went back to, he
came here to America,
he was in New York and
he was so guilt-ridden
that he left his people in this
dark hour that he went back.
I think it was on
one of the last boats
that went back and you
could get back into Germany.
He went back and he said
to all of his pupils okay,
let's say you're an atheist,
you really believe that,
but you don't have
any other choice
than to take somebody's life.
They didn't realize at
the time the example
he was trying to get
them to convince him
that there's no way
you could do that.
Or to accept, convince him that,
yes, I can do that, he's
involved with Von Stauffenberg,
he's taken to a concentration
camp in the end.
He's in a cell with a
guy who took the Jews
up into airplanes until
their heads popped.
He took people and
covered them in ice
and freezing in the cold
water and all of that stuff,
in every hospital in the world,
that book from the Nazis,
all of those stats are in
every hospital in the world.
And that's why he was sent
to a concentration camp
because Hitler,
he released all this
information and Hitler said,
what the hell are you doing?
And he said, you know how
many lives will be saved
by this information?
He said, we're
saving German lives,
not everybody's life.
He, a prostitute, double
agent, and Dietrich Bonhoeffer
were in the same cell.
They were all executed four
days before Hitler died.
The guy at the gallows
remembers Bonhoeffer
because he thanked him.
He walked up the
stairs and he got there
and the executioner
kind of helped him up
and then put the
noose around his neck.
And Bonhoeffer looked
at him and said,
thank you for your kindness.
Good gallows.
That's the person I want to be,
but that's not a
person you just become,
that's a person you
work hard to become.
- Glenn, I didn't know
what we were going to do
when we sat down.
I said to you, right,
as we walked in,
I said, let's just
figure it out.
You had some stuff here.
And this is truly like,
people can understand
this is half a percent
of some of the stuff
that you've got.
And and so you're
building this museum.
So where can people
go after this?
Because this is actually,
without me knowing what
we were going to do,
this is exactly
what I wanted to do.
And I think it's a nice
break from the minutia
of the day-to-day crazy stuff.
- So if you want to know more,
you want to sign up for the
classes again, they're free.
You'll just be notified,
we'll just have you on a list,
and we can shoot
an email out to you
and tell you it's happening.
Go to mercuryone.org,
that's my charity.
And look for the American
Journey Experience.
- Do you know when the
museum is actually opening?
I mean, I saw that you guys
are putting it together,
it ain't easy, COVID
and everything else.
- Yeah because of COVID,
I don't know, it was supposed
to be open last summer.
And it's just a mini museum.
We have plans for
a massive museum
that we're working
with the city on,
but hopefully as soon as
this COVID nonsense stops,
we'll open it up.
It will be open for
those who are willing
to have a test and
everything else,
you can come in and
actually take the classes
here at the center,
but most people will take
them online and it's free.
So just sign up.
- Glenn I think you're
on your way to becoming
one of those people,
how about that?
On your way, fair enough?
- Maybe, hopefully.
- Thank you,
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full
episode playlists,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.